ملاحم كرويه كانت في ظاهرها رياضيه لكن
بعطينها امتلا بابعاد سياسيه عديده شهد
عليها تاريخ كاس العالم عبر نسخه الاثنين
والعشرين الماضيه في نسخه كاس العالم
الثالثه عام
1938 خيمه الحساسيه على لقاء منتخب
ايطاليا الذي كان يمثل الفاشيه الايطاليه
في اوروبا ومنتخب فرنسا الذي قابل النشيد
الايطالي بصفارات الاستهجان في يوم فازت
فيه ايطاليا بثلاثه اهداف لهدف ايضا
مونديال المانيا عام
1974 كان موعدا للقاء الاشقاء الاعداء حيث
استمع منتخبه المانيا الشرقيه والغربيه في
ذلك الوقت بلقاء مشحون سياسيا انهته
المانيا الشرقيه بهدف باقي في الذاكره حتى
بعد هدم جدار برلين ولم الارجنتينيون حرب
جزر فوكلاند مع بريطانيا في مونديال
المكسيك عام 86 كانت حربا من نوع اخر في
استاد استيكا المكسيكيه الذي كان شاهدا
على هدفين تاريخيين للراحل مارادونا اقصيت
خلالهما انجلترا من الدوره ربع النهائي
لبطوله كاس العالم وفي مونديال فرنسا عام
98 كانت الاجواء متوتره للغايه بين
الولايات المتحده وايران لكن الرياضه
حكمتهما بلقاء اعتقد انه سيكون مليئا
بالحساسيه الا ان لاعبي المنتخبين وجدوه
فرصه للتهدئه تصافحوا وتبادلوا التذكارات
وفازت ايران في النهايه مسجله اولا انتصار
موندياليه لها